bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors expliquez nous selon vous
quels sont les enjeux de cette réforme
constitutionnelle au chili dans les
enjeux sont multiples comme vous l'avait
dit dans votre reportage
évidemment c'est mettre fin la
constitution héritée de la dictature la
période de autoritaire d'ailleurs il
faut souligner qu'aujourd'hui 5 octobre
on commémore aussi le 5 octobre 88
il ya eu un plébiscite pour dire oui ou
non à pinochet au dictateur et c'est le
oui qui l'avait emporté mais justement
cette période de trente années de
démocratie partiel néolibérale avec la
constitution autoritaire et bien c'est
ce c'est de ça que ne veulent plus une
grande majeure majorité des chiliens et
chiliennes et les sondages montrent qui
va avoir vraiment un tsunami en faveur
du oui à une nouvelle constitution
dans un contexte chaos si vous l'avez
souligné de très grande violence mais de
violence de l'état et des carabiniers
avec ce jeune hier qui a été jeté d'un
pont et qui est actuellement à l'hôpital
alors va revenir sur la constable à la
contestation sociale mais pour qu'on
comprenne bien
quel point de l'actuelle constitution
font débat aujourd'hui lorsqu'il faut
bien voir c'est que la constitution de
1980 qui a été donc instauré en pleine
dictature
c'est l'une des constitutions les plus
néolibérale de la planète elle inscrit
dans le texte constitutionnel le
fonctionnement du marché le marché
partout au chili et aussi c'est une
constitution très autoritaire qui
empêche toute modification
constitutionnelle si on n'a pas des
majorités qualifiées d co room
en gros l'idée à l'époque c'était de
donner à la droite des cadenas sur toute
avancée démocratique
et c'est cet état de fait qui
aujourd'hui apparaît comme une vraiment
une anomalie dans un pays qui se
revendique comme démocratique
alors à vous entendre la majorité des
chiliens à se prononcerait en faveur de
cette réforme constitutionnelle du côté
des autorités du gouvernement de
sebastian pinera qu'est ce qui se joue
avec cette réforme constitutionnelle est
bien là le gouvernement la majorité la
droite chilienne
une assez mauvaise posture du fait il
faut le souligner un ce qui a déclenché
toute cette transformation en cours
c'est la puissance du mouvement
populaire chilien depuis octobre 2019 et
la droite chili d'aujourd'hui est
divisée donc la majorité présidentielle
est divisé entre un secteur qui
finalement s'est résolu à dire oui à une
nouvelle constitution est un autre
secteur la droite dure qui est refuse
toujours et donc la position
présidentielle est très très complexe
puisque historiquement monsieur pigna
s'était opposé à une réforme à une
assemblée constituante
donc c'est vraiment pour l'instant le
mouvement social qui a impulsé cette
transformation mais avec des partis
politiques qui sont quand même très
frileux malgré tout sur une
transformation de fond
cette mobilisation citoyenne a débuté le
18 octobre 2019 à un vaste mouvement
populaire depuis le début c'est à dire
en allant de quoi ont pu profiter les
manifestants il réclamait plus de droits
sociaux qu'elle avançait à ce qu'elles
ont obtenu 16 ans monte au créneau
s'il est un peu le paradoxe de la
période
donc on parle d'un plébiscite d'une
assemblée constituante partiel à venir
mais sur la question des droits sociaux
qui étaient à l'origine de cette grande
mobilisation
et bien il y a eu quasiment aucune
avancée réelle et c'est là la difficulté
ça explique aussi que malgré l'ampleur
de la pandémie treize mille morts au
chili est bien la question des droits
sociaux les revendications sociales sont
toujours là et pour l'instant le système
politique le gouvernement n'y a pas
répondu tous merci beaucoup d'avoir pris
le temps de répondre à nos questions
franck gaudichaud je rappelle que vous
êtes professeur d'histoire et
civilisation de l'amérique latine